Since Keanu Reeves first hit Hollywood like
a cool breeze in the '80s, he's saved humanity
from robot slavery, kept a doomed bus from
exploding, and even made out with Paula Abdul.
"Whoa"
But even though Reeves is a pretty prolific
actor, he remains far more enigmatic than
many other celebrities… until now!
Here are some things you may not know about
Keanu Reeves.
Bard brain
Thanks to his roles as dumb guy Ted in Bill
and Ted's Excellent Adventure and dumb guy
Tod in Parenthood, Reeves was in danger of
being typecast in the early '90s.
"Now what?"
That's why it was something of a surprise
when Kenneth Branagh cast Reeves as Don John
in his 1993 screen adaptation of William Shakespeare's
Much Ado About Nothing.
But Reeves had actually been performing Shakespeare
for years, dating back to a 1985 production
of Romeo and Juliet at a Toronto theater school.
And My Own Private Idaho was based on Shakespeare’s
works.
How much does he love Shakespeare?
He turned down a $12 million offer to star
in Speed 2 so that he could play Hamlet in
a stage production in Manitoba, Canada.
Now that's love...
"I had rather be a canker in a hedge than
a rose in his grace!"
Haunted by...a jacket?
While living in the New York area, young Reeves
encountered what can only be described as
a ghost.
A ghost jacket, anyway.
There's really no explanation — so let's
just have Keanu tell the tale himself:
"There's a doorway.
All of the sudden we're looking over there
and this like jacket comes waving through
the doorway, like just an empty, there's no
head, there's no body, there's no legs, it's
just there.
And then it disappears.
And I was a little kid and I thought 'Ok well
that's interesting.'
And then I looked over at the nanny, and she's
like this."
Whoa.
He can’t quit smoking
While smoking is often a youthful indiscretion,
Reeves was well into adulthood before he picked
up the habit.
He says he started doing it on the set of
the 1996 comedy Feeling Minnesota because
his character was a smoker, and then he just
got hooked.
He's called smoking "a prison" that he'd love
to quit, but can't.
Personal tragedies
Reeves endured multiple heartbreaking tragedies
in rapid succession.
He met actress and production assistant Jennifer
Syme in 1998, and the two fell in love.
In 1999, Syme and Reeves were expecting a
child together, but when Syme was almost full
term, doctors discovered the baby had passed
away.
The stress of the loss of the child contributed
to the demise of their relationship.
Less than two years later, while driving home
from a party at Marilyn Manson's house in
Los Angeles, Syme was killed in a single-car
accident.
She was only 28 years old.
Charity work
Reeves is very close with his sister, Kim
Reeves, who was diagnosed with leukemia in
the '90s.
Filming on The Matrix Reloaded and The Matrix
Revolutions was reportedly delayed so Keanu
could spend more time with his sister and
help nurse her back to health.
In Kim's honor, Keanu has donated huge amounts
of his time and money to cancer charities,
hospitals, and research facilities.
"I have a foundation that does some, it's
mostly directed towards healthcare."
And he also works with organizations like
the SickKids Foundation and Stand Up to Cancer.
Film crew favorite
While negotiating his contract for the two
Matrix sequels, Reeves scored a bunch of "back
end" points, meaning he'd make a portion of
the movie's box office take in addition to
a salary.
Instead of taking all the cash for himself,
Reeves diverted the money to the Matrix trilogy's
costume and special effects teams, essentially
donating millions so the movies could be completed
after the production nearly ran out of cash.
He also bought each of the trilogy's 12 stuntmen
a Harley Davidson—his way of saying "thanks."
Pay cuts
If Reeves really wants to work with an actor
he admires, he isn't above foregoing a portion
of his usual salary to help make it happen.
He reportedly did exactly that so that he
could star in The Devil's Advocate with Al
Pacino and in The Replacements with Gene Hackman.
"What's it gonna be Shane?"
"I want the ball."
"Winners always do."
Motorcycle man
Reeves loves motorcycles so much that he started
his own business, the Arch Motorcycle Company,
whose signature product is the Arch Motorcycle
KRGT-1.
Designed and built with his friend and Arch
co-founder, bike architect Gard Hollinger,
the custom built "superbikes" have two V-twin
engines and cost $78,000 each.
Rad Keanu
Reeves has often been an inspiration for memes,
viral pictures, and the overall delight of
the internet.
Among the most famous: a viral video of Keanu
giving up his subway seat to someone who needed
it more.
Then there's this uncanny 16th century painting
from the Uffizi Gallery in Florence, Italy,
which seems to suggest that Keanu is actually
a time traveler himself.
And of course, there's the infamous Sad Keanu
meme.
Which actually made Keanu kind of… sad But
not that sad.
"I mean, do I wish that I didn't get my picture
taken while I was eating a sandwich on the
streets of New York?
Ya."
Not quite the Wyld Stallyns
Shortly after the release of the Bill and
Ted movies, Reeves formed a garage band called
Dogstar...in his actual garage.
"I played in a band called Dogstar and we
made a couple of albums.
I played electric bass."
At their first gig, an up-and-coming band
called Weezer was their opening act, and Dogstar
even played The Tonight Show.
(Keanu Reeves slapping bass in his band Dogstar)
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment and let us know which
fact about Keanu Reeves surprised you the
most…